ألقت ميليسا نظرة على بعض الاختراقات القراد ،
لذلك هناك بعض الخبراء الأنيقين
هناك أو على الأقل يعتبرون
أنفسهم بعض إجراءات النوم ، وأعتقد
أنه مجرد شيء
يجربونه هذه الأشياء التي جربوها ، لقد نجحت هذه الأشياء
بالنسبة لي ، ربما  سأعمل من
أجلك أيضًا ، سأضعه على
علامة صباح الخير روبن نعم
، يقسم المستخدمون بحركات النوم التي يبدو أنها
تعمل مع بعض الأشخاص
مثل هذا الشخص لا يصلون إلى هاتفك
إذا كنت بحاجة إلى تذكر
شيء مهم في منتصف
الليل بدلاً من ذلك تخيل نفسك تضع
هذه الفكرة داخل غطاء وسادة
ثم في الواقع ترمي وسادة على
الأرض وتذهب للنوم ، لذلك
عندما تستيقظ وترى الوسادة
في صباح اليوم التالي ، يجب أن تهز
ذاكرتك أو
ماذا عن نصيحة النوم البارد هذه
عندما تكون على وشك النوم ، قم
بخفض درجة الحرارة ،
فهذا يساعد في إرسال إشارة إلى عقلك
بأنك متعب وحان وقت
النوم
الآن يدعي رجل أن شيئًا ما قد
يكون لديك في مطبخك
يمكنه  كن مفتاحًا لمحاربة الأرق ،
فأنت تعاني من الأرق وتواجه صعوبة في النوم ،
وتناول موزة ، فهي تحتوي على المغنيسيوم
والبوتاسيوم
يساعد عضلاتك على الاسترخاء ، وتحصل على
نوم
جيد ليلاً ، وعندما يتعلق الأمر بالنوم الجيد ،
يقول مستخدم آخر أنك بحاجة للتخلي
عن هاتفك في  وقت النوم
لا يجلب هاتفك للنوم ، تأكد من
أنك في غرفة مظلمة في درجة حرارة محيطة
مما سيساعد على زيادة الميلاتونين عند
قراءة كتاب
أو الاستماع إلى الموسيقى الشائعة ،
لذا قدم روبن بعض المتحدثين الآخرين بالقراد
نصائح مثل الكتابة  في إحدى المجلات قبل
النوم ، أذهب للنوم في نفس الوقت
كل ليلة ، أحاول أن أفعل ذلك
أو أحسب عدد الأنفاس التي
تأخذها بدلاً من عد الأغنام ، كنت أعتقد دائمًا
أن
الملاءة الهادئة كانت غريبة بعض الشيء ، ما
يساعدك على النوم. أتذكر أنني
تذكر بالأمس أنك ذكرت
شيئًا ما عن الميلاتونين ،
نعم الميلاتونين ، هناك مثل مكملات النوم هذه
التي
لا تجعلك تشعر بالسوء في اليوم التالي
والتي جعلتني  لاتونين أو حشيشة الهر
يشبه المكمل ،
مكمل طبيعي لأشياء من هذا القبيل أو
أنا أحب الحمام الساخن في الليل هذا
ما يعجبني وكوب من
الشاي أحتاج فقط لأن أكون أفضل في النوم
وهذا كل ما أعنيه لا  كلنا
بالرغم من ذلك